si con esta demanda trump y su defensa a
sus abogados pues se buscan que los
archivos nacionales y que el comité de
la cámara de representantes pues no
acceda a las conversaciones ya los
documentos y a las reuniones que donald
trump el ex presidente tuvo antes del 6
de enero día que se ocurrió la toma al
capitolio del otro para argumentar que
tiene fuero presidencial para que los
archivos nacionales no revelen esta
información y no accedan a esa
información los miembros desde el comité
de la cámara de representantes sin
embargo ya la casa blanca se ha
pronunciado y le ha dicho a los archivos
nacionales que pues tiene toda la
potestad de revelar esta información al
congreso y a las personas que lo
requieran porque pues ese finalmente el
presidente en funciones es decir yo
bailé en el que decide cuáles son los
límites del fuero presidencial al que
apela donald trump para que estos
documentos y esta información sobre sus
reuniones antes del 6 de enero no se
conozcan es que cristóbal hoy
precisamente se reúne el comité para
votar y preparar el reporte contra este
barón ex estratega de donald trump que
se espera esta reunión que sigue después
claro y es que lo que el comité trata de
indagar es que fue exactamente lo que
conversaron steven y donald trump el 30
de diciembre supuestamente en esta
conversación banon le dice al ex
presidente de trump que se enfoque en el
6 de enero y ahí puede estar la
respuesta para que se quede en la casa
blanca en todo caso se reúne el comité
hoy vota para que este reporte entonces
se ha llevado al pleno de la cámara de
representantes después la cámara de
representantes votaría en plenos y este
reporte y esta acusación de omisión y de
desacato a pues la orden que le dio el
congreso es tiene el valor de
presentarse y de entregar esta
información pues es llevada entonces a
el departamento de justicia
normalmente el departamento de justicia
pues no pasa a
enjuiciar a estas personas que no
cumplen con la orden de información por
parte del congreso lo que llaman el sub
fina pero pues dado que esto se trata de
la toma al capitolio de que es un evento
bastante especial pues se puede esperar
cualquier cosa sin embargo el proceso es
lento recordemos pasa por este comité
pasa después por cámara de
representantes y después pasa al
departamento de justicia quien pues es
un judicial izaría finalmente así ven
banner por desacato